todavía son visibles los restos de la
masacre flores frescas que se cambian
cada día para acordar a las víctimas del
bombardeo este mercado el pasado día 4
de abril al menos 10 personas murieron y
decenas resultaron heridas los vecinos
de la zona siguen consternados
cuando las bombas cayeron salí a la
calle horrible de un cuerpo aquí tirado
en el suelo
en la unidad de cuidados intensivos de
este hospital los supervivientes más
graves del ataque siguen luchando entre
la vida y la muerte mientras las sirenas
de alerta no dejan de sonar
ellos no disfrutan nuestro trabajo debe
ser salvar vidas personas que están muy
enfermas que han tenido un accidente
grave no a civiles heridos por los
bombardeos un voto capta tapa
la ciudad mykolaiv está siendo
constantemente bombardeada por tierra y
mar desde el inicio de la invasión rusa
hoteles en el centro de la ciudad
edificios de la administración y
vecindarios han sido los objetivos
portucel y carne la línea del frente y
no han cambiado lo que son continúan
bombardeando diariamente edificios
civiles las públicas hospitales para
crear pánico entre la población es una
guerra psicológica en contra la
población ucraniana disney piscina acb
dizque alguien ha sobrevivido en
bombardeo en su barrio los fragmentos de
un misil le impactaron las ventanas su
vivienda y guarda los restos de la
metralla que no se exhibe como podemos
mirar estos son trozos de una bomba de
racimo primero oí la explosión de un
misil y después la metralla entró por la
ventana la rompió completamente y todo
lo que tenía aquí es culpa de esa los
ataques diarios nikoláy de resiste sus
habitantes se preparan para un inminente
ataque a gran escala sacrificando sus
simbólicos álamos para fortificar la
ciudad